it's Michael Hill sniper on the hill
I'll get him oh you got him no you
didn't get him I do if you did a
backflip oh that was fantastic Adam and
James baby bok sitio game Oh games I
don't little jamesburg video games yeah
hello and welcome to Adam and James play
video games I am indeed Adam and I am
joined by James hello aight then I'm
quite looking forward to this cuz I
usually prefer shooting you in the head
but this time I'm gonna shoot with you
well it looks like y'all playing my dad
so well played out yeah yeah although we
both sort of resemble potatoes if you
look at our heads we do I mean we're
very very tanned right now I don't know
if that's the sunset it might be the
sunlight yeah the sunset got a bit of a
Donald Trump very nice blue blue polo
above your head which really helps I see
you are you've got that on my end so so
what we have to do today is get through
the next level where we have to destroy
guns so like heavy armor guns that's our
job and we gonna do it with stealth is
that right we'll try we have our weapons
we have our buy them by knock you Lars
Oh work it baby work it anyway it's time
to shoot some Germans no let's not call
them Germans let's call them nazis
specifically nurses yes they are not
Germans just Nancy's not all Germans are
Nazis just a lot of them are well there
goes the German audience thank you very
much kids oh [ __ ] go back go back oh no
right well there goes the stealth it's
all right you didn't see is that lasted
30 seconds all right I coming it I'm
gonna shoot me I did Oh No alright
everyone just run away that's what we
gonna do we can burn bag of the
following your lena relocate I've gotta
know to write it right to write that
hasn't tagged him on me
I'm gonna have to shoot him he's gonna
see us go for it try and shooting and
killing them yeah yeah preferably one
shot next time i got that war aliens
down there's another one on the way and
we need to relocate don't we oh if we do
there's a guy right in front of you okay
I'm just gonna kill this guy stealth
stealth knife to the neck I've got one
far in the distance I can see one okay
just so we put them put where's here
let's put them on this big red shiny
barrel I don't know why is red and shiny
let's blow the hell up blow them the
hell up blow the hell well it is
Hellfire isn't it oh fire fire have you
tried running whilst carrying a dead
body not in real life now it's quite
difficult that's all I'm saying I
managed to get him on the year you
didn't look turn around oh oh do you
fancy taking him out while we're doing
this cuz he wont to dinner you always
seen as he see all we nearly nearly
nearly alerting them okay nice throw
that would take all its bloody
breakdancing brutal oh no that's another
150 our carton is fine yes 50 you
knocked him off he was already off on my
end oh he wasn't oh oh we get different
renders well luckily done check shall we
kill more of these guys than is that
what you saying yeah and then bring him
back oh I might find a better spot he's
after me here I might have to go stealth
love I'm coming swallow him oh I'll stab
him in the neck I'm gonna get that guy
long range cuz I've been dying to for
ages okay he's all yours I'm gonna take
this guy back to the blow-up point oh
right in the head he's got off a
freaking phone or in here I in my mind
that was German and I realized as soon
as i started i was doing south african
but i'm not nicest sniper elite oh i
just threw a guy and he went through the
Bridge aye well let me act they won't
let me talk him through the bushes Oh
carefully around Oh No okay I've given
us a way I'm sorry all good there's so
many not tagged you've got out yeah boom
I didn't even get him I got ants wicked
wasn't he did no you did shoot him
though but no he wasn't dead don't worry
i was on hand literally I just blew up
see [ __ ] for the fun of it oh did it die
he did I did I o-neck stabbed plus
quarter take down there we go whoa oh
Kim try yeah that's me at the top trying
to get these guys before they get to you
I'll tack up are you going oh you know
oh you know oh it's not he'll sniper on
the hill I'll get him why you got him no
you didn't get him I do if he did the
backflip oh that was fantastic this
vehicle was just growing in the air the
one who own yacht for me the one you
threw is on the wall yeah and is the one
might go to sleep next to it here now
he's on the ground is it look like he's
going to sleep though
a little bit he's almost in the fetal
position I reckon we're getting
different versions yeah you got that
three two one go do you know where the
barrel is neck and neck I do know the
where the rail is yeah I'm gonna try and
squeeze you out of this corner I'm ahead
of you I've got a good foot four and a
half advantage oh you've gone too far
that's not even speaking no talking Nazi
tosses nothing don't like toss food
let's say oh no I've got bad news I've
got very bad news go on all the bodies
are vanished get on yes yes right i SWA
I'm gonna shoot it if you got a good
angle in fact why don't you join them
all right then I wish we could take
selfies shall we aim fire and nothing
happened nothing happening so he's still
now looks like The Exorcist is
levitating over the fire wow its heat
levitating on your end he's a he's got
his head on one yeah that count that's
terrifying oh no we have to blow it up
don't we I wouldn't be that close to it
if I were you there underneath Oh
got it you think next boom like in the
head oh [ __ ] we've get ourselves up well
we're gonna cells away oh I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die jumpy I'm bleed it out I
can see you in the bottom can't right
okay okay let me think this I could
still shoot all right you can shoot when
you die Thomas just with a pistol
clicking the pit if you go there the one
running oh it's okay pas dead where have
you gone out it's okay I've got this
covered snipers who need snipers is that
enough we killed them all I'd really
need your help I'm gonna bleed out I'm
coming I'm coming dude re it's all good
let's hope I've got a bandage now
holding your hands there you go thank
you welcome back to the fight hello
shoot round first either there is nice
aha God through ill gown that was so
good right I reckon I'll show you i
think first here see this tank yes oh
this thing he it blows up this thing
here yes i think lord your body down
here okay let's get many as we can
definitely okay I'm just gonna spread
the bodies of it
that what very very suggestive right I'm
gonna shoot it are you ready right I'll
see if I'd get a nice char they swish
like I'll go the other side to get a
different perspective where you gonna go
you're gonna shoot straight forward I
reckon we're gonna get a little cutscene
and they're all kind of vanish okay are
you ready right I'm ready here we go
three two one oh the bear ah only one
rolled over a little bit well we took
out the tanks always find the positives
right Jim's yes what we're going to do
in this next section oh he's not running
around we're going to tag everyone and
we are not going to use these weapons in
our hands we're just go walk into a wall
we're just going to use the strength of
our fists our feet and knives okay dad
okay right good luck sir we've really
got to focus on stealth here instead it
isn't it this way yeah is this way
stealth so del this table they be arnes
barrels yeah sec I'm gonna get the one
in the fast and then we both peg it the
other guy the third guy did you nearly
nearly say you're gonna get the one on
the far right because i was gonna say
they're all on the far I Adam then
artsy's oh I thought you did that well
done can you get that guy now i can get
to my mind if you can get to yours yes
Oh is he see me so me I gotta go I'm
going to get the other group guy oh well
isn't running through him what we can do
guys looking straight hours he's not
he's looking at the wall oh okay i'm
tryna stay always oh yeas is spotted me
okay i'm gonna try going down oh that's
not going down on him but you know what
I've been laying down going prone what
we gonna do now oh yes he's my god oh my
god i see it can see makin teammate you
can see me it contain mr.
stay still sits back move back it's
really can't see where i am now boast
I'm gonna go oh god Ronnie Stanley run
logo will be it got away with it did you
yeah it's coming around though well he's
facing the other what noise turn east at
least facing me right now okay we have
to really fix it well it might now
there's a guy coming down from your
bird's nest come on stealthy teams del
Sol in fact I've got an idea I've got a
rock I'm gonna throw a rock oh yes oh
that's not a rock that's not the wrong
robot they all start Oni ously shut
themselves he's quite beyond geez coming
behind you come around the side in fact
Adam that's worked they're all in a
similar position now right go down the
middle I'm coming down what we gonna do
now right ahead of you there's four
should we just charge them if you go
left oh don't meet I'll go left you go
right or what yeah i'm just gonna change
it I'll go left oh they're not bothered
don't know come back to normal we got it
oh no oh no oh oh that was close oh that
was close they've seen us at our album
go get the along before I die yes like I
got to me yeah yeah dad well do my
celebratory circle dance what you forget
to say celebratory circle jerk father
and son this is gonna be a lariat we
just attacking we had just run in this
is father and son at its best right
there's three guys up here got the one
on the left is that door okay I've got
the one on the right and there's another
one somewhere in the cave oh just got
the one on the stairs my heart rate is
too high to do it properly just freehand
it then got it
no oh you love nice one thank you all
let's do this hey you're dead nice one
oh well played right that was perfect
this might say him off so beware beware
beware of the period mean but be alrigh
was a right bunch be Wed Coco beware I
think we have to snipe the other gonna
cross yay far over that side yeah okay
it's always some guys to tag maybe have
you nice one yeah oh ok we haven't tank
we were tank to take out all we have
attacked to take out oh is it coming
towards me it is [ __ ] hell it's
coming towards me right I've taken down
one and a half of the things on its ass
I've got one oh it's turned around now
you get it did it oh that wasn't
underwhelming that's much better well
that was surprisingly easy yeah oh sorry
oh it vanished it vanished that you know
that's what happens to tanks it towed a
day totally evaporates the dying got to
Nancy heaven there we go
we did it we shot some people I'll come
live all arrived now after we've cleared
it just to us bastards they were just
waiting there all the love that was Adam
and James play Sniper Elite 3 if you've
enjoyed this video please like share and
subscribe and help us reach more than
five people for our content we're doing
this every week for a few weeks now
until people say they've had enough so
thank you for watching and we will see
you next time